okay the holiday buying season is
starting to get to the end and of course
if you ever shop on amazon.com the
shopping you do can support us if before
shopping you go to david pakman.com
slash amazon that's all you do you type
in david pakman.com slash amazon it will
redirect you to amazon and then you just
shop a bunch of people over the last
week clearly getting ready for some
travel buying those rick steves travel
guides I actually know a little
something about Rick Steves I I've
always thought he was just this kind of
seemingly introverted guy who does these
PBS shows where he tours places and
shows you where to go turns out he is
hugely successful in a multi
multi-million dollar business these
travel guides that he writes and the
shows allow him to promote a lot of
those books very interesting and far
more successful than I think a lot of
people give him credit for well that's
fantastic yeah he is an intelligent guy
and and whenever I'm traveling somewhere
I'll always check out the videos that he
has online before going there yeah he he
really does tell you how to have a sort
of less touristy experience in a lot of
places so some smart people in our
audience also the most expensive item
purchased over the last week from our
david pakman show amazon link is an euro
home Wi-Fi system for nearly five
hundred dollars thank you to whoever
bought that and thanks to the hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of items that
were purchased through the link remember
david pakman.com slash amazon that's the
way to make your amazon purchases
support the david pakman show